este texto seguirá su camino democrático
fue preparado por el gobierno Después de
varios meses de concertación luego fue
revisado por el gobierno y modificado
después de la concertación con el
parlamento son 175 horas de debate este
texto es el fruto del camino
parlamentario ha sido enriquecido por la
comisión mixtaparitaria luego votado por
el senado y luego fue adoptado por la
asamblea luego de la utilización del
artículo
10493 y luego después del fracaso de una
moción censura contra el gobierno ahora
va al consejo constitucional hay que
esperar que se pronuncie este y luego de
su decisión
se promulgará el texto y ese esto
usted insiste en esta fecha de primero
de septiembre claro pienso que para que
las cosas se establezcan tanto para que
de aquí a fines de año para cerca de dos
millones de nuestros compatriotas un
millón ochocientos mil para que puedan
saber el aumento de suspensiones cerca
de 600 euros para año por año en
promedio también
tres meses por año se irá adelantando la
edad legal para ir a la jubilación
también se aumentan los trimestres que
hay que empezar a trabajar más
progresivamente todo
en este momento Claro que toca esperar
la decisión del Consejo constitucional
bueno la crisis social será uno de
nuestros temas la crisis política
también pero primero quisiera
preguntarles sobre unas palabras suyas
que quizás le molestaron a alguien se
dijo que las multitudes no tienen
legitimidad frente a la voluntad de los
representantes elegidos legalmente
quiere esto decir que lo que los
manifestantes son ilegítimos No gracias
por esta pregunta
he visto que algunos parlamentarios han
sido agredidos de manera inaceptable
estos días y lo digo solemnemente somos
una gran nación y un pueblo antiguo
sus
directivos han siempre
sido elegidos popularmente
irresponsables
los que están Opuestos a esta reforma
los respeto están defendiendo su punto
de vista de hecho el derecho a la
manifestación es protegido por la
Constitución de hecho el gobierno y el
parlamento
intentan tener en cuenta estas
manifestaciones e integrar sus
peticiones es pero al lado de esto en
este momento de nuestra democracia
cuando hay algunos grupos que utilizan
la extrema violencia para agredir a
representantes elegidos de la República
alcaldes desafortunadamente Todas las
semanas está pasando esto cuando
utilizan la violencia sin ninguna regla
porque no están contentos con algo eso
ya no es aceptable ya no es democrático
aquí estoy intentando aclarar las cosas
mis palabras intentan aclarar cuando los
Estados Unidos vivieron lo que vivieron
en el Capitolio lo mismo en Brasil la
extrema violencia en Alemania en Países
Bajos o a veces en el pasado aquí en
Francia lo digo claramente se dice uno
respeta y uno trata de avanzar
pero no se puede aceptar
la violencia
hay que escucharlos y hay que escuchar
la ira y hay que responder a ellos sí
porque con sus palabras usted hace
referencia al desbordamiento pero que
dice a los que van a manifestar mañana
noveno día de
manifestaciones quiere decir que ya no
hay nada para negociar es el fin del
partido bueno Primero quiero decirle que
significa este texto para qué se adopta
Usted cree que para mí es agradable
hacer esta reforma no no cree que
hubiera podido poner el mugre debajo del
tapete como han hecho otros sí quizás lo
hubiera podido hacer tal vez pero
Lamento que no hayamos podido compartir
la restricciones es la necesidad de
hacer esta reforma Hoy hay 17 millones
de pensionados en los años 30 habrá 20
millones cree usted que podemos
continuar con las mismas reglas cada vez
se llega más tarde a la vida profesional
y es una oportunidad llegar cada vez más
tarde tenemos un sistema Por repartición
que hace que seamos nosotros los activos
los que estamos financiando las
pensiones no estamos financiando las
nuestras Entonces no hay 83 soluciones
Mientras más espere la situación se
degradará cada vez más esta reforma es
necesaria yo se lo digo a los franceses
no no me alegra hacerla pero por eso
Pienso que hay un sentido de la
responsabilidad esto se hace en interés
general es la situación demográfica
hubiéramos podido decir que bajamos las
pensiones pero la respuesta es no
nuestros pensionados no tienen mucho
poder adquisitivo no podemos bajar las
pensiones vamos a otra solución habría
sido aumentar las cotizaciones de los
activos pero también tenemos un problema
de poder adquisitivo debido a la
inflación
Y por qué no hacer participar las
empresas digo no así no funcionan las
pensiones las pensiones son aportes de
los activos para los pensionados
pero el desequilibrio lo tendría que
financiar el presupuesto del Estado
Entonces qué podríamos hacer Aumentar
los impuestos Pero somos uno de los
países occidentales que tienen los
impuestos más altos yo espero en la
Confío en la red industrialización del
país yo creo que vamos a ganar esta
batalla también podríamos decir que
dependemos de las prioridades que hay
que invertir en los servicios públicos
las escuelas la salud pero no podemos
tomar este dinero para pasarlo a las
pensiones Entonces cuál es la fórmula
mágica que es un proyecto de todas las
de todos los que se oponen la solución
sería el déficit Pero qué es el déficit
de hecho significa que se elige hacer
que sus hijos paguen porque hoy en día
ustedes no quieren ser valientes
tengo una pequeña infografía aquí para
mostrarles somos el país de Europa que
junto con Suecia que tiene nuestro
sistema y nuestro modelo los demás
entran a los 65 años o más sí conocemos
sus argumentos pero
por qué no lo han comprendido
Por qué no se hizo pedagogía desde el
principio lo que yo les digo es que esta
reforma no es un lujo ni un placer es
una necesidad del país
usted piensa que lo ha explicado mal no
pienso simplemente que hay una voluntad
de pasar a otra cosa y de no hacerle
frente entre todos a esta restricción a
esta dificultad
puede uno Tener razón solo en contra de
todos los demás
habrá elecciones presidenciales y
parlamentarias pero
No todavía hay muchas cosas que se han
dicho no se han dicho sobre las
pensiones incluso las rabias que se
expresan Hoy no están hablando de las
pensiones sino de otras reglamentaciones
hay que escuchar a todo el mundo y hay
que ayudar a todo el mundo muchas de las
rabias no son sobre las pensiones de
esto volveré a hablar pero nuestro
sistema hoy tenemos que reformarlo y lo
asumo la responsabilidad y lo hago en
interés general hay una parte de las
oposiciones que tienen un sentido de
responsabilidad y hay que respetarlos y
asociarlos a nuestro proyecto la mayoría
en el senado no es una mayoría que
normalmente apoya al presidente de la
república esta mayoría enriqueció este
texto y lo modificó adoptó algunas cosas
que va en el mismo sentido varios de los
representantes de la oposición que
vienen de la derecha republicana
decidieron votar este texto y no
aceptaron la moción de censura hay que
respetarlos
Lamento que ninguna fuerza sindical haya
propuesto
una con una un punto intermedio los
sindicatos hubieran podido proponer un
hacer una propuesta alternativa pero no
Simplemente dijeron No queremos reforma
usted no cometió ningún error presidente
sí no he logrado convencerlos pero al
mismo tiempo me doy cuenta de que hay
una tendencia en nuestra en nuestra
democracia que quieren abstraerse del
principio de realidad y Esta es una de
las consecuencias de una situación post
en la que muchos de nuestros
compatriotas las fuerzas políticas y
sindicales el secretario general de la
cft por ejemplo aquí en estimo propuso
aumentar la duración y
nadie aceptó sus propuestas pero nos
hubiera propuesto a nosotros un punto
medio no es una propuesta alternativa
pero por ejemplo 64 hay una aceleración
de la duración de las cotizaciones pero
no hubo una solución intermedia
Entonces el texto se hizo con el
parlamento y tenemos que avanzar es el
interés superior de la nación y les digo
los digo con asumiendo mi
responsabilidad yo ya no puedo ser
reelegido No lo puedo ser
constitucionalmente pero entre los
sondeos a corto plazo entre las
encuestas a corto plazo y el interés
general del país el hijo el interés
general del país y esta sería mi
elección
de movilización
ante esta situación tan difícil que se
ha degradado tanto que les dice ustedes
qué les dice usted a estas personas
los bloqueos los amotinamientos en las
estaciones etcétera Bueno hay diferentes
formas de manifestación y quiero usted
ya me permitió aclarar aclararlo si hay
manifestaciones para decir estoy en
contra de eso es legítimo y me alegra
del espíritu responsabilidad de la
totalidad de los sindicatos que se han
mostrado su oposición aunque no han
presentado una propuesta alterna pero lo
hicieron calmadamente y de manera
organizada
al lado esto hay bloqueos y hay
violencia la violencia hay que
condenarla
están los bloqueos y los bloqueos hay
que poderlos levantar cuando impiden la
actividad normal y por eso
por eso le pedí al gobierno que
intentara al máximo negociar y luego dar
órdenes
en algunas grandes ciudades por ejemplo
en el caso de la refinerías por ejemplo
pero cuando Se volverá al orden o a la
vida normal en la vida de los franceses
el orden republicano por supuesto es lo
que yo deseo yo yo me comprometo me
comprometo a lo que depende de mí
estoy seguro de que hay que buscar un
camino ahora y hay que negociar en torno
a la mesa pero los franceses están
comenzando a cansarse claro tienen razón
y ya lo dije no vamos a tolerar ningún
desbordamiento Esperamos que la vida lo
más normal posible se pueda restablecer
frente a quienes están bloqueando la
actividad por eso damos órdenes de re
anudar
yo El Ejecutivo debo tratar de entender
la cólera legítima que no es la
violencia sino todo lo que se ha
expresado en el momento de estos
cuestionamientos siempre las hemos
tenido cada vez que se han reformado las
pensiones y a veces mucho más
y En qué situación estaríamos si en
1993 o en el 2010 para citar algunos
ejemplos no más de reformas anteriores
qué tal que mis predecesores se hubieran
detenido y hubieran dicho no no hacemos
reforma estaríamos en una situación aún
más crítica Por eso digo que hay que
hacerla
ahora qué es lo que expresan estas voces
que manifiestan primero una sensación de
injusticia usted lo evocó un poco cuando
lo de las empresas hace un momento ese
sentimiento de injusticia es decir
siempre somos nosotros los que
trabajamos y Es verdad Esta reforma sí
le estamos pidiendo a los a las personas
que trabajen más sí le estamos pidiendo
que hagan un esfuerzo para financiar el
futuro
comprendo esta necesidad de Justicia
Pero hay dos excepciones hay empresas a
las que hemos ayudado Y continuaremos
con estas políticas de apoyo a la
empresa porque esto permite
reindustrializar el país pero hay un
problema cuando hay algunas empresas tan
grandes que tienen tantos beneficios y
utilizan ese dinero para recomprar sus
propias acciones ahí yo sí le pido al
gobierno que se les imponga una
contribución excepcional para que ese
dinero cuando hay utilidades
excepcionales
que estas empresas en lugar de recomprar
sus propias acciones que los
trabajadores puedan beneficiarse no
porque es que esta sobre imposición de
las utilidades excepcionales
ya las hemos trabajado
por eso es que podemos subsidiar la
energía por eso es que su electricidad y
su gas no valen tanto como deberían bala
porque esto se debe a la a los impuestos
sobre las ganancias excepcionales de las
empresas Pero algunas empresas están
haciendo esto que ya dije entonces se
necesita que distribuyan más a los
asalariados y que contribuyan a este
esfuerzo del momento en segundo lugar
Algunos trabajadores dicen usted nos
piden que hagamos esfuerzo y hay
personas que no trabajan nunca y tienen
casi la misma vida y tendrán la misma
pensión por eso es que es muy importante
rápidamente
Buscar a todos estos que reciben este
subsidio y llevarlos al empleo para que
entiendan la situación Esta es una de
las partes importantes del futuro es
decir derechos y deberes reforzados para
quienes se benefician de este subsidio
y también hacer que vuelvan al empleo
algunas personas que hace muchos años no
están trabajando
eso es lo que usted está diciendo hoy
para apaciguar los ánimos Sí porque hay
una necesidad de Justicia Sí y al lado
de esto está lo que vimos en la calle
también protestas sobre el trabajo mismo
muchas personas con razón
he escuchado en la industria
agroalimenticia en Bretaña
la industria en el centro de Francia
algunas trabajos de la salud los
trabajos de los acueductos de
alcantarillados Hay personas que dicen
estamos cansados agotados pero si somos
honestos no el problema no es 62 o 64
años el problema es 55 o 58 años
tanto los el gobierno como los
parlamentarios en este texto
han contemplado el desgaste profesional
Entonces esto es parte de la solución
hay que tenerlo en cuenta dar una
respuesta a esa ira legítima y una
respuesta Bueno yo espero habrá que
esperar unos días unas semanas pero hay
que hablar con los con las partes
sociales sobre este desgaste profesional
la reconversión al final de la carrera
la actualización de las carreras
Por qué esperar tanto para ver mostrado
estas para haber hablado de estas
reformas de estas partes
ya lo empezamos a hacer
el
Cuando se expresa la rabia usted hace
propuestas suplementarias No si yo como
si yo comenzara diciendo que todo lo
hicimos bien me dirán usted estar loco
usted no está escuchando a las gentes
que protestan no pero cuando el pueblo
se expresa Esa es la democracia hay que
escuchar la cólera legítima y hay que
responder a ella entonces estas
respuestas que ya estamos empezando a
dar no son suficientemente fuertes y
tangibles tenemos que ir más allá el
desgaste profesional de carreras la
reconversión también
la progresión de la carrera hay algunas
personas que dicen Sí hay personas que
no trabajan Entonces ya lo dije hay que
responder con la ley de trabajo y el
sistema de derechos y deberes de quienes
se benefician de este subsidio de
solidaridad otros dicen que el trabajo
no paga suficiente ahí también ya les
digo hemos hecho mucho en el 2010 2019 y
sin establecimos la prima de actividad
ahí
hacia décadas que no se aumentaba el
poder adquisitivo también se aumentó el
salario mínimo en nueve y medio por
ciento más que la inflación pero hay que
escuchar lo que nos dicen nuestros
compatriotas que están manifestando
sobre este tema y no sobre las pensiones
sino que el trabajo debería pagarles
mejor pienso que
hablemos Tenemos que hablar con las
sociedades general para qué miremos en
todas las ramas que están por debajo del
mínimo legal en el salario mínimo porque
hay muchas ramas de trabajo que siguen
pagándole a la gente menos del salario
mínimo usted nos está hablando de las
diferentes partes sociales
y cuáles son las partes políticas en fin
todos los que tengan que ver con el tema
fundamental tenemos que encontrar
rápidamente una respuesta para estos
trabajos y estos oficios
que no están ganando el salario mínimo
integral
hay que abordar este tema y resolverlo
también hay que trabajar el tema de las
carreras una ley no va a cambiar las
carreras porque no somos una economía
administrada hay que volver a poner
sobre la mesa el diálogo Social para que
las carreras permitan ganar mejor su
vida estamos en uno de los países donde
el salario mínimo es de los más altos de
Europa pero el salario promedio es decir
por encima y por debajo del cual hay
algunos y otros
Este es un mínimo en Europa entonces las
carreras están aplastadas en nuestros
países y esto es desesperante para
muchos de nuestros compatriotas hemos
encontrado respuestas por ejemplo
subimos las cotizaciones sociales
el impuesto sobre las horas
suplementarias en fin
se podría por ejemplo cambiar de ser yo
podría cambiar de sector y trabajar en
un oficio donde no me cansé tanto en fin
todo esto es diálogo social señor
presidente
Cuál es el papel de la primera ministra
Elizabeth Perdón termino con este tema
lo que yo quiero es seguir el diálogo
social muy rápidamente con estos temas
pero cuando ya en las próximas semanas
tomémonos tres semanas un mes para
definir el método no se requieren
grandes discusiones sino una discusión
honesta ya empezó a usted a llamar a los
sindicatos pues harán una manifestación
mañana y respeto su manifestación ya los
llamaré pero detrás de todo está el
sentido del trabajo Esto me sorprende se
necesita mucha benevolencia y mucha
paciencia y mucho cuidado algunos
manifestantes
han dicho Es que lo que pasa es que no
queremos trabajar más Y esta es una
crisis en muchos países occidentales
tuvimos ayudamos mucho durante el covid
y todo se desajustó en ese tiempo por
eso se requiere ahora mucha
responsabilidad porque durante muchas
veces pagamos para que la gente no
trabajara para proteger al país la gente
encontró otros equilibrios entonces hay
que reconstruir esa relación con el
trabajo no son son compromisos
que el gobierno y qué Primer Ministro
usted confía todavía en su Primer
Ministro su primera ministra Elizabeth
Sí yo la nombré Ahora tiene ella que
pues tiene que ganarse la confianza del
parlamento ella decidió después de haber
examinado con las fuerzas políticas de
la mayoría y sus ministros para que esta
reforma pasara con toda seguridad ella
quiso comprometer la responsabilidad de
su gobierno eso es lo que se llama el
49,3 el famoso artículo
esto ya se ha hecho antes en nuestra
quinta República es un gesto solemne
ella le dijo al parlamento si usted
tiene es una mayoría alternativa que se
exprese el lunes se demostró que no
había una mayoría alternativa
faltaron nueve votos Sí pero en la
democracia un voto hace la diferencia
esta vez fueron nueve motos faltaron
nueve motos Sí pero en un momento
incluso incandescencia política no hay
mayoría alternativa entonces vuelvo a la
primera ministra confía usted en
Elizabeth tiene su confianza duradera
para varias semanas para varios meses
Claro Ella tiene mi confianza para
conducir a este equipo gubernamental
sobre le solicitado sobre las bases que
acabamos de explicar que construya un
programa legislativo y un programa de
gobierno
en de acuerdo con el presidente del
senado y de la asamblea nacional para
que al mismo tiempo haya menos textos de
ley de textos más cortos y más claros
para también que las cosas para nuestros
compatriotas pases cambien de manera más
tangible no todo pasa por la ley en
nuestro contexto hay que actuar al
servicio de las prioridades de nuestros
compatriotas hacerlo de manera muy
concreta con los elegidos con los
representantes en el terreno aquí se
pasa demasiado a través de la ley y
también que construya un programa de
gobierno para que las cosas sean más
claras ambiciosas Y apaciguantes en este
contexto la el mandato que le di a la
primera ministra es que constituya
amplia que continúe ampliando esta
mayoría lo más que se pueda con los
hombres y mujeres de buena voluntad de o
de izquierda o del lado de la ecología
que estén dispuestos a ver las
prioridades y a trabajar con ella y
avanzar con ella quizás contexto sí
obviamente Se podrían hacer acuerdos de
coalición No lo hicimos al comienzo del
Ingenio porque no es nuestra tradición
política
Sí pero tengo que mirar
eso no se hizo al comienzo del
quinquenio pero sí hay que estimar Y
respetar a muchos parlamentarios
vinieron que apoyaron este texto y no
eran la totalidad de un partido Por eso
digo que es difícil construir
coaliciones hay individualidades
políticas con sus convicciones que están
dispuestas a trabajar con las fuerzas de
la mayoría deseo entonces que la primera
ministra pueda construir esta ampliación
de la mayoría en las próximas semanas y
espero que lo logre en cuanto es de
alivio del método habrá algún cambio no
habrá reorganización de su gobierno no
habrá disolución no habrá referente
usted no va a cambiar nada en cuanto al
método
el método no es lo que usted acaba de
decir esos son hechos políticos lo que
yo estoy diciendo es que en
responsabilidad tenemos que avanzar
aplacar reconstruir una agenda
parlamentaria
trabajando con los sindicatos y todas
las fuerzas políticas que estén
dispuestas a hacerlo ese método tenemos
que volverlo a lanzar pero al lado de
esto mucho de esto lo estamos haciendo
desde hace un año Por eso es que ha
habido tantos textos sobre los cuales se
han ido tomando decisiones a pesar de
algunas oposiciones bueno ha habido
textos sobre la energía muy importante
es para nuestra seguridad y nuestros
compatriotas también hubo reformas sobre
el seguro de enfermedad
seguro de salud para poder ir hacia el
pleno empleo y luego dentro de la idea
de aplacar los ánimos
todas las fuerzas de las dos cámaras
deben ponerse de acuerdo y comprometerse
más en el terreno para dar una respuesta
a nuestros compatriotas ahora después de
todo lo que ha pasado usted me dirá que
no está condenado al inmovilismo quedan
cuatro años de mandato
Ya vimos que el plan cosas que ha habido
prorrogadas y también hay la ley de
inmigración llegará a las al senado la
próxima semana que justamente eso fue lo
que decidimos ayer con el presidente del
senado y el presidente de la asamblea
vamos a reorganizar las cosas y vamos a
hacer textos más cortos si habrá una ley
de inmigración habrá varios textos sobre
la inmigración y llegarán en las
próximas semanas ahora para nuestro país
no tenemos el derecho de parar ni de
quedarnos quietos no tenemos ese derecho
muchos de nuestros compatriotas se
expresan este miedo porque tienen miedo
al cambio a los trastornos hay una
sensación de que se está perdiendo nivel
de vida dicen que nuestros servicios
públicos están cada vez
si esa fue la palabra que utilizó Edgar
Philip el inmovilismo
Sí ayer una de las responsables de la
mayoría Durante la reunión de
concertación para comprometer a todo el
mundo eso decíamos no tenemos el derecho
eso lo dije en 2017 y ahora
También estamos acá porque durante
décadas
acostumbramos al país a gastar y no
producir más o producir cada vez menos
entre 1980 y 2010 aún antes de la crisis
financieras destruimos más dos millones
de empleos industriales y seguimos
gastando entonces acostumbramos a
nuestros compatriotas a decirles que que
ya que nada va a pasar que nuestro
modelo Social es formidable que no
tenemos que trabajar más pero eso es una
mentira eso no funciona Qué estamos
haciendo desde el 2017 estamos librando
esta lucha del pleno empleo y la
reindustrialización es el núcleo de esta
batalla y la estamos logrando
colectivamente pasamos desempleo del 9%
a 7% hoy los mayores de 50 años ya están
en un 5% de tasa de desempleo el más
bajo la más baja desde hace 15 años
también la tasa de actividad más alta
desde que se empezó a medir y estamos re
industrializante abrimos más industrias
de las que se cierran también hemos
creado más empleos industriales y ese es
el núcleo de la batalla Y esto qué
supone que hagamos que tomemos
decisiones Fiscales como las que tomamos
para las empresas Si queremos
reindustrializar se requiere más trabajo
y más capital en nuestro país y en
nuestro suelo
reindustrializar sectores que han
sufrido mucho por ejemplo uno de los
bastiones de nuestras baterías
eléctricas para nuestro país y para el
continente en fin los ejemplos son
múltiples Seguimos avanzando a marchas
forzadas porque este balance estos
éxitos según usted el empleo la raíz
Por qué los franceses no se dan cuenta
de esto y por qué están furiosos
pienso que hay que desconfiar de esa
palabra en los franceses y los franceses
no percibieran nada y estuvieran todos
furiosos seguramente no me habrían
reelegido hace menos de un año y la
mayoría sería relativa etcétera hace
menos tiempo o sea hay algunas personas
que están furiosas eso no quiere decir
que todo esté bien para todos porque hay
algunas cosas que funcionan no todas
Pero algunas sí funcionan estamos en una
situación que se basa en una especie de
ilusión y estamos tratando de realmente
comprometer al país sobre el futuro con
el futuro
el pleno empleo y la red
industrialización eso es la Francia de
2030 tenemos que volver a hacer una gran
nación de investigación de innovación de
producción Y por qué no haber hecho esto
antes de la Reforma de las pensiones
que lo estamos haciendo desde hace cinco
años
quiero ser claro sobre eso que usted
está diciendo cuando yo digo esto en
2019 a ver lanzamos las ordenanzas de
trabajo ya están funcionando Hace seis
años me Expreso en una sociedad que ya
tiene una tasa de desempleo menor en
2017 propuse crear un sistema Universal
de pensiones y no mover
la edad de inicio de jubilación porque
no había problema en ese momento pero
qué pasó en nuestro país después En qué
mundo estaban viviendo pasó la pandemia
del covid una guerra hubo inflación la
nación gastó decenas de miles de
millones de euros para proteger a los
ciudadanos nuestras cuentas se
degradaron en el momento de la campaña
de 2022 la situación era drásticamente
diferente comenzamos a ganar la batalla
por el pleno empleo bajando desempleo en
un 2% comenzamos a reindustrializar
y la respuesta empezó a darse y todos
los expertos dicen Sí hay un problema
con el sistema de pensiones fue la
opinión de los expertos Y sí entonces
hay que poder avanzar entonces la
situación de 2022 no era la misma de
2017 Bueno usted nos ha presentado
varios planes de trabajo para los
próximos meses Si queremos ser concretos
Cuál cuál será el tema emblemático no la
medida emblemática son así no funciona
la sociedad O sea mis temas son re
industrialización y pleno empleo para
2030 hay que ganar la batalla de la
industria descarbonada el pleno empleo y
los textos que vamos a presentar para
que los que están más lejos del empleo
vuelvan a trabajar y
mejorar todo el tema del trabajo y luego
los republicanos
la gendarmería más jueces
fortalece el sistema judicial para
luchar contra la pequeña delincuencia y
luego un trabajo militar Para
apoyar a nuestros ejércitos para
protegernos y la tercera prioridad es
escuela salud y ecología escuela Quiero
que en el próximo año académico año
escolar
hay que apoyar más a nuestros
estudiantes hay que responder en la zona
rural hay una baja de efectivos a veces
habrá que cerrar es algunos
establecimientos escolares pero la
respuesta llegará con las clases
multinivel los internados en fin hay que
responder a las necesidades de la zona
rural en educación
hay que ser justos con nuestros jóvenes
y facilitarles el empleo Sí hay muchos
temas de trabajo porque tenemos inmensas
ambiciones educación salud para que haya
un hay 600 600.000 médicos para nuestros
compatriotas Ese es el núcleo de la
convención médica que está preparando el
ministro hay muchos ciudadanos que no
tienen un médico tratante
y
lanzar la reforma de los hospitales para
mejorar las condiciones de trabajo y
arreglar el problema de los desiertos
médicos también
si ya ganamos la batalla por la
seguridad energética ahora tenemos que
ganar la batalla de la sobriedad en
materia de agua todos Tendremos que
hacer algún esfuerzo para preservar
nuestra agua mejor reutilizar mejor el
agua el agua de lluvia las aguas lluvias
por ejemplo cambiar los usos bosques
transportes vivienda todo esto es
Ecología y tenemos que darle el
acompañamiento para una transición justa
y sostenible pleno empleo Ese es el
rumbo pleno empleo re industrialización
orden republicano y una mejor vida
problemas con la educación la salud de
la ecología algo más personal señor
presidente usted fue elegido en 2017 y
el año pasado en 2022 con la promesa de
ser el presidente de todos los franceses
Y lograr reunir a todo el mundo ese era
uno de sus eslóganos de sus eslogans
nosotros todos pero el país parece más
fracturado que nunca ahora usted mismo
lo dijo tiene usted una sensación de
haberse equivocado en algo cree usted
que ha perdido la manera de comprender y
de hablarle a los franceses No yo le
quiero decir algo la reforma que estamos
haciendo es muy difícil realmente le
estamos pidiendo a la gente que haga un
esfuerzo esto nunca es popular nadie nos
compite y no estamos compitiendo con
nadie en el sentido de la
responsabilidad nos ayudan mucho
asumo este momento lo asumo porque
permite el resto de trabajo
quiero continuar con el compromiso con
los territorios Yo veo que hay algo de
vitalidad de todas maneras en el terreno
hay muchos franceses y francesas que
están dispuestos a unirse para
ayudar
en todo el trabajo que tenemos que hacer
o sea usted no lamenta nada
yo le digo nuevamente Sé que esta
reforma es necesaria yo no vivo de
lamentaciones ni de lamentarme yo vivo
de tenacidad vivo del compromiso porque
amo al país llamo a nuestros
compatriotas Entonces yo trabajo para
hacer lo que hay que hacer siempre hay
que asumir momentos difíciles pero sigo
trabajando para que a todos y todas nos
podamos comprometer en estas
transformaciones
de lo que hablo es del compromiso
colectivo Porque todos tenemos algo que
aportar al Porvenir de nuestro país
cuando hablo de salud de educación de
Ecología algunos días después del último
informe del díac Sí todos sabemos que
todos tenemos que aportar Seguiremos
trabajando en el terreno Ese es el nuevo
método también es un texto difícil hay
que lograrlo Pero
creo que es un esfuerzo de todos Yo sé
que Nos podremos unir para el futuro del
país estoy convencido Muchas gracias
señor presidente gracias a ustedes